with Frank viverito Frank you are with
it with the st. Louis sports commission
and you have been tasked with spreading
the news about st. Louis and the place
as a city that it should have more and
more of these kind of events so what do
you do to make this happen well our
mission statement is very simple we're a
nonprofit organization we want to make
st. Luce a better place to live visit
work and play through sports and and
that is done through events we bid for
events we bring all types of events to
the region our organizational resume
includes just about all the Olympic
sports that you can think of many of the
collegiate sports and you know we work
with different partners in the region
the the hotels the tourism organizations
the the sports organizations the
university's our political institutions
and try to be a gathering place a
promotion place a bidding place to bring
major events to our region now st. Louis
loves its Cardinals and loves his
baseball yep would you have thought that
it would become the chest capital of the
United States well don't ever
underestimate st. Louis okay that's the
first thing and the second thing I would
tell you is that st. Louis has the
richest sports history of any city in
the United States really yeah seriously
I'm from New York I'm not buying that
absolutely absolutely and it's not
defined by wins and losses it's always
defined by wins and loss not at all not
history is not necessarily defined by
wins and losses clear you're not a
Yankee fan oh I am I am as a matter of
fact you are a Yankee fan am I getting
this on air yeah growing up my two
favorite teams growing up in New York
City where I'm from my two favorite
teams row is the Yankees and whoever was
playing the Mets okay and so now I have
the Cardinals and the
Yankees Wow I gotta like you that that's
the best DoublePlay combination in
baseball but back to st. Louis sports
history we are the home of soccer in
America we are the home that the the
heart of tennis in America the heart of
boxing in bowling in America a great
history in baseball the forward pass and
football was invented in st. Louis and
Samuel this was the first place in the
United States to host the Olympic Games
and so is America's first Olympic city
we also created the Senior Olympics in
st. Louis that in terms of diversity and
in terms of depth that at per capita
even this is a fabulous sports history
city and the sports history of this
region has created great sports fans and
the combination of a rich sports history
and great sports fans is what makes st.
Louis such a wonderful sports town do
you pledge yes yes I did you play
drexciya I haven't played Rex yet but I
have to tell you that I graduated from
high school in New York City 1972 and
Shelby Lyman and Spassky Fisher was
literally the talk of the town for that
entire summer so that's all we did that
summer was was play chess in fact I
still want to go to Reykjavik Iceland
just because that's where that that
that's where those matches took place
and and you know it's a it's a wonderful
activity and and in to our mind and
wonderful sport well the Golden Age of
chess in 1972 and America is seeing a
golden age of chess right here in the
city of st. Louis Frank Oberle thank you
very much for joining us we appreciate
your insight no better place for it
thank you yep well i still have gonna
argue about that best sports town in the
country I'll take you on any guys can't
just can't but interesting data to say
the least for st. Louis certainly
represents no question about it